this is what remains of a 12-story
apartment block on florida's atlantic
coast
it happened while they were sleeping at
1 30 a.m
people nearby thought it could have been
a piercing crack of thunder
the truth was far more traumatic
a cctv camera capturing the moment the
building came
down with no warning for dozens of
people inside
apartment units ripped in two by the
force
lives torn apart we just toured
around the complex to be able to see
and the tv doesn't do it justice i mean
it is really really
uh traumatic to see the collapse of a
massive structure like that
one person died 10 were injured 99
are still unaccounted for for those
waiting to hear from loved ones
it's unimaginable just today friends of
the family had decided to stay the night
of all days they chose the worst one to
stay there and then this happened
they were trying to get away from the
covid situation in argentina which is
really complicated at this time
it's a family that's worked really hard
their entire lives
they were finally able to adopt their
young daughter after years of much
sacrifice and now
the three of them were in there we have
friends who have family that live in the
building
you know we don't even know if they're
okay some of them are okay
we don't know if the rest are okay we
really like it's just you know like
it's like it's very shocking
there were 134 apartment units in this
building
more than half were destroyed from the
side
still standing residents were winched to
safety
some had been barricaded inside their
homes by the sheer weight of the debris
there was initially hope as this young
boy was carried from the rubble by
firefighters
who began the rescue operation despite
the risk of the entire building
collapsing
sniffer dogs are being used to detect
signs of life
this community is mostly home to
families
retirees and those seeking sunshine on
florida's sandy beaches
the search and rescue operation
continues
the inquiry into why this building came
down with
such devastating consequence has already
begun
martha kellner sky news florida